blake lively is calling her hubby out on
his thirst
trap hard look at her she's turning red
she's blushing no we've ruined her the
33 year old actress took to her insta
story to share a screenshot of a message
she sent to ryan reynolds
after he posted this snap that's the 44
year old actor
setting a turtle on the ground while
wearing a white
short sleeve t-shirt well after seeing
her husband's post
blake sent ryan a dm reading quote are
we supposed to believe this
isn't a post about your finest arms she
really does
just show me how to be better in almost
every way as a father as a person
everything in a follow-up post the 33
year old actress reposted the pic
labeling it exhibit a and she zoomed in
on the shot
in her next two posts to further show
off her husband's muscles
and i'm drooling
we keep our family together it's really
important for us to have that support
system so we're always there
always together but this isn't the first
time blake and ryan who share
three daughters together six-year-old
james four-year-old inez and
one-year-old betty have trolled each
other online
he's pretty funny back in may the couple
went to a new york yankees game
and blake shared this pic of their
outing hilariously writing alongside it
quote
i love meeting fans we have fun we're
best friends so
you know and a month earlier ryan made
fun of blake for a costume she wore in
her 2020 flick
the rhythm section he compared her look
which included a blue beanie to the
outfit he wore while getting vaccinated
asking fans to vote on who they thought
wore the look better
naturally blake reposted his insta story
writing quote
my husband trying to troll me while he's
looking like a bernie meme
and life aquatic with steve zizu had a
hot
offspring just for your visual reference
here's the bernie sanders meme she's
referencing and
here's bill murray in life aquatic she
has a point
but she also said he was like a hot
offspring of the two
so her dig is still pretty freaking
sweet
i was actually really grateful for for
for that but it isn't all public
trolling in the reynolds lively house
during ryan's recent appearance on the
smartlist podcast the deadpool 3 star
opened up to host
jason bateman sean hayes and will arnett
about when he first met blake
saying they were friends first i met
blake on the
on the darkest crease in the anus of the
universe called green lantern
and we were friends and buddies and then
um
about a year and a half later we
actually went out on a double date but
we were dating separate
people we hung out and kind of you know
we were we always kind of kept in touch
but sort of
casually and then next thing you know
she was going to boston i was going to
boston so i was like well let's
i'll i'll ride with you i'm present with
my kids
and my wife and my marriage is
incredibly important to me and that
friendship is important to me
and he revealed why they don't take on
projects at the same time
blake and i don't do movies at the same
time so she's ready to go back and do
some so i'll step
down and and then you know we'll we go
back and forth you guys alternate
yeah she'll yeah she'll do a film and
i'll just be you know with her on
on location hanging with the kids
[Music]